[Musique]
j'ai 21 ans et je suis en 3e année de
prépa littéraire aussi chef SCO à
mi-temps et là cette année en fait j'ai
aidé le père Maximilien à préparer le
voyage humanitaire au Burkina Faso avec
16 autres personnes des
Yvelines
l'idéal c'est que ça dépasse pas 23 kg
mon grand frère était parti au Bénin
avec le père Maximilien et il m'a dit il
faut vraiment que tu ailles en Afrique
au moins une fois pour voir ce que c'est
et j'avais dit au Père Maximilien si
jamais tu as besoin d'êide pour un
voyage humanitaire je serai là parce que
j'ai toujours ça m'a toujours plu
justement de partir à la rencontre des
autres et qui plusit de partir en
Afrique donc c'est vraiment l'attirance
pour l'étranger pour l'aide le goût de
l'aventure un petit peu aussi qu'est-ce
qui t'attire dans cette rencontre les
journées nationales de la jeunesse
burkinabaise qu'on fait du 2 justement
au 5 août où les les jeunes burkinabais
chrétiens se retrouvent à banfor pour
fêter comme les JMJ leur appartenance à
la foi chrétienne en tant que délégation
étrangère on va aussi rencontrer ces
jeunes burkinaba et ce qui m'attire
aussi c'est de partir rendre des
services dans des villages aux alentours
de banfor et donc là on va dormir dans
les familles normalement c'est un par
famille donc c'est vraiment c'est
excellent on va pouvoir vraiment toucher
du doigt la culture qui burkinabaise et
les modes de vie et les personnes
l'aspect rcontre pour moi c'est
ça Frédéric tu viens de rentrer du
Burkina c'est
ça comment ça s'est passé ça s'est très
très bien passé au niveau de l'ambiance
au sein du groupe comme on était un
petit petit groupe de 16 entre 20 et 25
ans on on s'est tout de suite bien
entendu ce qui fait que le voyage a été
génial puis même au niveau du paysage du
pays des gens c'est c'est excellent il y
avait deux parties dans ce voyage il y
avait la partie JNJ donc à
banforora c'est au sud du Burkina Faso
où là on a tout de suite été très bien
accueilli par à la fois la la
congrégation religieuse qui nous
accueillait sur place et on a été aussi
très bien accueilli par des jeunes qui
étaient sur le lieu des JNJ en fait
que disent les jeunes catholiques
rencontrés là-bas beaucoup de questions
sur les autres religions notamment parce
que au Burkina il y a une majorité de
musulmans et une minorité de chrétiens
donc il y avait beaucoup de questions
qui tournaient autour de l'entente entre
les religion et il y avait beaucoup de
questions sur la foi aussi sur le le
futur les choses comme ça c'est
impressionnant d'arriver et de de voir
qu'il y a vraiment un échange entre les
musulmans et entre les catholiques par
exemple d'inviter des musulmans à venir
fêter le 15 outo et que les musulmans
nous invitent à venir fêter laïde moi ça
m'a beaucoup marqué parce que c'est
c'est inattendu un petit peu mais avec
les problèmes qu'il y a eu au Mali
certains en tout cas de la jeunesse ont
peur que ça dégénère aussi au Burkina
Faso il se pose beaucoup de questions
sur leur place dans l'église sur
l'église aussi sur leur foi parce qu'ils
se rendent compte qu'en Europe bah la
place de l'église est beaucoup remise en
cause on a eu un moment où on a échangé
avec les jeunes et il y a un jeune qui
nous a posé cette question mais vous en
France vous croyez de moins en moins en
Dieu comment on sait nous si on est sur
la bonne voie en fait la deuxième partie
on est parti à Boni donc c'est un petit
village toujours dans le sud de Burkina
Faso où là en fait on a rendu trois
services donc on ait aidé à repeindre la
salle principale du presbytère là où les
gens viennent pour les les grandes
réunions les grandes célébrations là où
les gens viennent faire des prendre le
repas donc c'est vraiment la salle de du
village c'est l'équivalent de notre
salle paroissiale c'est ça ouais et on a
vu que ça faisait plaisir aux gens de
voir que la salle renaissait un petit
peu parce que c'est vrai qu'au début
elle était un peu en mauvais état et
donc on a repeint on a mis des brasseurs
d'air pour que ça soit beaucoup plus
agréable ensuite on a creuser à l'entrée
de de la mission une une rigole en fait
pour canaliser l'eau de pluie parce que
en Afrique quand il pleut il pleut
beaucoup et donc ça évite en fait de
détruire totalement la route le
troisième service qu'on a fait c'est de
planter des arbres donc à pas c'est
toujours dans la commune de bony on a
planté des arbres contre l'avancée du
Sahara voilà pour lutter contre la
sécheresse et ça ça a duré une dizaine
de jours
environ comment on revient d'un tel
voyage quand on revient et qu'on va à la
messe en Europe on se dit que c'est
vraiment deux mondes différents et je
pense que les l'église européenne a
apprendre de l'église africaine et les
gens célèbres et de toute tout leur
corps en fait et c'est c'est génial
on on se rend compte que en
France déjà on a beaucoup de chance euh
d'avoir les transports en commun
d'avoir des des infrastructures d'avoir
un état
présent on se rend compte aussi d'avoir
l'électricité l'eau courante commentc
l'eau courante là-bas l'eau courante en
Afrique c'est marcher 50 m pour aller
chercher de l'eau dans un pluie et
revenir c'est ça le courente en Afrique
là où j'étais dans ma famille il y avait
pas l'électricité ce genre de voyage ça
fait beaucoup éféchir sur notre mode de
vie et sur la façon dont on pourrait
changer notre mode de vie éviter de
gâcher de la nourriture alors qu' y en a
pas choses comme ça ça peut déjà aid et
toi tu en récupères aussi autre chose
beaucoup de souvenirs et puis beaucoup
de de sourire en fait de gens qui nous
ont dit merci de ce qu'on a
[Musique]
fait